alors jean edouard oui le pistent jésus
la cervelle de quoi bein jésus d'accueil
c'est l'histoire en fait un peu du
milieu de la prostitution dans les
années 20 à montmartre à travers les
digues d'un jeune prostitué homosexuel
c'est son amour qu'il a envers une
prostituée d'un certain âge ans qui
retrouve un peu un côté maternel et qui
est marie laforêt tout à fait voilà et
voilà l'histoire se passe à montmartre
dans le milieu des démarches loup est
effectivement alors au départ marie
laforêt assez mal réagi elle vous
appelle vous dis mais enfin il faut pas
qu'on fasse cette pièce ensemble enfin
tu n'es pas comédien avant olympiques et
pour ça elle t'a appelé pour ça oui ben
c'est ça la seule fois où elle m'a
appelé c'était pour me dire écoute je
suis derrière toi quoi qu'on puisse dire
c'est pas parce que tu es né de la real
tv qu'on n'y arrivera pas moi je trouve
qu'il se trouve super donc apparemment
il ya eu un premier coup de fil où elle
s'inquiétait en disant ils veulent faire
de quelqu'un d'autre mais en tout cas
c'est comme avant c'est pas toi non
c'est un droit non parce que moi la
version que jc quelques appels une
première fois en te disant c'est un coup
de fric bon voilà et qu'après ltte
rappel en disant banon finalement quand
elle a vu ta première réplique elle a
dit tu joues bien y'a pas de problème le
premier coup de téléphone je n'ai pas vu
elle s'est trompée bah oui elle s'est
trempé le problème c'est qu'à cause du
loft été obligés d'être excellent parce
que c'est vrai que ça c'est terrible on
ne pardonnera rien tu comprends pourquoi
on le trouve bon il faut que tu sois
excellent j'aurais aimé tu le sais ça
bah ouais non parce que le vcb en même
temps je le prend plutôt bien c'est
plutôt logique parce qu'on a commencé à
être connu avant d'avoir fait quelque
chose donc logiquement canton
les choses vont un peu plus vite donc si
on est moyen bon et mauvais si on est
bon on est moyen et très bon ben on est
moins correct voit donc on essaye d'être
très bon coin il faut que tu sois très
bon bah ouais je fais un peu tout cas je
fais tout pour alors tu dis j'en ai
assez que l'on pense que je n'ai rien
dans la tête j'ai quand même fait un an
de droit et j'ai un bts d'action
commerciale
d'antigel la question n'est pas cool
pourquoi mais celui-ci une déclaration
qu'il a fait lui non c'est pas c'est pas
le fait d'avoir fait les études qui me
rendrait plus intelligents mais c'est le
fait que la télévision parfois rend les
gens un peu plus con c'est à dire que
vis-à-vis du public bas on enferme dans
une image ou untel est méchant
et pas uniquement pour les gens de la
télé réalité1 pour tout le monde intel
est méchant et ça va même jusque chez
les comédiens ou quand un comédien et
joue tout le temps les rôles des bandits
vont finir par dire que c'en est un donc
c'est qu'il ya un moment où on a envie
de remettre les choses à leur place et
d'expliquer aux gens que c'est pas parce
que on a c'est une émission de télé
ralité qu'on aime connaît pas et qu' une
certaine image et de vous a été
accentuée que obligatoirement elle vous
appartient autant de paddy des études on
a juste dit un bts d'action commerciale
au moins alors ce qui est terrible c'est
que les gens de la télé réalité ils ont
du mal parce qu'ils sont devenus
célèbres avant d'avoir fait quelque
chose donc après il faut nourrir cette
notoriété c'est très compliqué donc toi
tu en es là et puis surtout toi tu es
devenu célèbre dans cette scène bon du
vrai et du losc avec loana donc c'est
vrai que d'un seul coup ça va être
difficile de faire oublier ses
consultations dans la piscine le
problème des gens de latéralité pour
certains c'est de nourrir la notoriété
et moi mon show n'était pas de nourrir
la notoriété mais de véritablement faire
un travail de fond et sur le long terme
donc c'est pour ça que depuis un certain
temps je me fais discret je me plains
pas non plus que tous les gens viennent
me voir pour revenir sur un plateau
parce que je pense que de temps en temps
vous me fermer sa gueule que parler pour
rien dire alors vous dites jean-edouard
avec loana nous n'avions pas conscience
de tourner un film porno notre contrat
stipulait qu'aucune scène de sexe ne
serait diffusé c'est vrai ça tout à fait
où est dans le dans le contrat et est
bien stipulé que justement tout ce qui
pouvait toucher à la sexualité ne serait
pas diffusé donc bah moi je fais aura
jouteurs jeu qui sauvent sous l'eau
signez ici
non ya les
bons nasri
quelque chose que je pense beaucoup
d'autres auraient fait et sans se
soucier que les caméras filment et parce
que pour nous elle fonctionnerait pas à
ce moment là donc on a fait et puis
voilà est ce qui a été fait a été fait
on assure à ce que vous a reproché c'est
pas ça parce que ça à la limite
effectivement tout le monde aurait été
ravi de le faire et qui est censé passer
gerald moi ce que je fais ce boulot il a
changé de sexe
je n'ai pas loin jean michel non
jojo
non mais ce qu'on vous a reproché quand
même c'est d'avoir laissé tomber ouais
c'est ça qui a quand même handicapé vos
chances de gagner c'est que voilà tomber
quoi à loana je sais pas moi ça s'est
fait d'un consentement mutuel et au
départ oui mais après je veux dire vous
vous dites bon on avait tous les deux
envie de tirer un coup puis le lendemain
elle est venue me voir me disant qu'elle
était amoureuse qu'elle voulait se
marier bah ouais mais ça vous paraît pas
bizarre justement que une fille puisse
venir vous voir et vous dire j'ai envie
de me marier avec toi le lendemain un
truc pareil bah ouais c'est moche quand
on s'accroche ou dans une telle
situation peut
donc là c'est logique que je réagisse
comme ça je pense que beaucoup de monde
réagit de la même façon sans vouloir
faire de pub on est dans courir à 30 ans
la 17 euros au diable vauvert mais rien
vraiment c'est ça la lâcheté enfin j'en
parle énormément d'encourir intense et
ça c'est qu'est ce que c'est que le
guide de survie de nos joueurs du mal de
vivre masculin c'est aussi la lâcheté
comme la dépression comme l'ironie comme
donner c'est ça et c'est pas grave il ay
là il était dans l'instant quoi dans
l'instant la peau saine a eu ce matin
vient le voir elle lui dit cham heureuse
de toi pourquoi on se marie pas lui par
en cours - d'aller ça m'intéressait pas
donc en même temps j'ai été honnête elle
est plus loin de la lâcheté que de dire
le ballon ça m'intéresse pas d'aller
plus haut alors ensuite j'ai eu une
petite romance avec jennifer de la star
ac
c'est vrai c'était celle inverse dans là
c'est l'inversé celle inverse c'est à
dire que là vous avez complètement
craqué jean-edouard
lettres en vous dévoilant ce qu'il faut
jamais faire un commentaire nicolas qui
est un spécialiste de l'âme humaine vous
le dira mieux que moi mais c'est vrai il
a écrit une lettre en se dévoilant une
lettre d'amour elle lui a reproché son
manque de maturité tu vois ah ouais non
je sais pas s'ils n'ont peut-être pas
peut-être est-ce que à ce que donnait
est ce que quand on est moi je suis je
suis le genre de garçon qui quand je
suis amoureux jeudi tout tout de suite
pour beaucoup de gens c'est souvent un
manque de maturité que pour beaucoup de
gens il faut maintenant il faut aller il
voit une certaine n'a pas fait si la
logique non moi j'ai pas fait de cinéma
comme jours et voilà comme je dis alona
ça n'intéresse pas d'aller plus loin
belge j'ai dit voilà ce que je pense je
vais dit ça m'intéresse d'aller plus
loin et quand j'aime quelqu'un je lui
dis je lui cache pas quoi donc ces êtres
c'est très mature je pense pas ça être
honnête et dévoiler ses sentiments je
pense que c'est la meilleure des choses
à faire il est bien ce genre et des
mails à genre edwards a raison il faut
passer en sept ans pour tomber amoureux
des gens parfois voilà il dit était
tombé amoureux de jennifer vraiment tu
l'a écrit une lettre indiquant les
rennais ont laissé passer cette chance
non pas du tout non c'était une aide
parce qu'un soir chez avait un soir elle
était enfin en droit et elle m'a dit
j'ai envie de te voir et donc j'ai fait
le déplacement qui était comme un long
trajet et je suis resté juste une nuit
lendemain voilà je vais laisser une
lettre avait comme dans le dix ans que
je pensais
enfin voila j'ai enfin ça venait du
coeur et après la fait souffrir à lui a
posé des lapins ils ont échangé des
propos aigres-doux enfin ça s'est mal
terminée est-ce que vous avez souffert
jean-edouard bas je pense que quand on
aime quelqu'un et que ça se passe comme
ça ouais on en souffre un minimum donc
ne fait pas trop souffrir louis quand
même
ils sont encore huit à être
intégralement érotisme depuis jennifer
ya rien eu non y'a rien n'y a rien eu
depuis jennifer fait eu d'autres filles
mais pas de l'aventuré mauvaises
aventures amoureuses non juste mais la
wii là vous êtes concentré sur la pièce
et ouais ouais enfin c'est plutôt ça
cette aventure c'est le travail sur la
pièce sur quelle pièce jésus lacaille de
carco adapté par frédéric dard à
l'espace cardin à partir du 16 avril
voilà là vous vous concentrez sur marie
laforêt je me concentre sur la pièce et
sur l'ensemble des comédiens qui jouent
avec moi parce qu'une pièce je pense
qu'avant tout c'est une troupe c'est pas
juste un premier rôle est donc c'est
c'est partager enfin y'a pas une pièce
avec un acteur il ya une pièce avec une
troupe est donc ce soit le dernier
dernier commet le dernier rôle le second
rôle le premier rôle je pense qu'ils
aient chacun a son importance il a pris
tous les tics des comédiens au débat
pierre arditi télé c'est lamentable mais
j'ai souvent entendu déjà en faire le
reproche justement est certain qu aux
médias de ne parler que d'eux quand ils
font la promo d'une pièce de théâtre
mais je pense qu'une pièce de théâtre
avant tout c'est pas un comédien c'est
une troupe est une pièce de théâtre et
c'est pas un seul comédien sur scène qui
va faire tout même chez les fruits de
mer c'est normal de citer tout le
plateau
alors c'est vrai j'aurais de voir que
vous êtes interdite de piscine nord plus
de 30 départements fin j'étais pas au
courant mais je vous le dis en même
temps j'ai pas refaire les 32 avant
c'était moi c'est betty la piscine
[Musique]
jean-edouard vous avez refusé de
participer à cette cette chanson ouais
des lofteurs ouais pourquoi parce que
l'époque bas à vendre parce que moi
j'avais commencé le théâtre j'avais 8
ans et donc mais pour me permettre de
gagner ma vie à côté de mes études
j'étais j'étais dj est bon ou mauvais
quand je suis sortie du loft et que j'ai
voulu continuer là dedans en attendant
pour payer mes mégots mais cours de
théâtre j'ai dit bas
même si ce sera difficile car il me
faire à une crédibilité dans le milieu
de la musique électronique et j'ai
estimé que c'était pas en faisant un tel
titre que j'y arriverai voilà donc j'ai
préféré dire non alors que je suis sûr
que les gens sont incapables de les gens
pensent que vous ce qu'il a fait mais
moi l'intérieur de savoir que je n'ai
pas fait j'en suis d'autant leur est
refusé à peine dame mais vous
n'échapperez pas jean-edouard à une
interview à peine 2
[Musique]
attention
ce que vous préférez en vous
mon coeur ce que vous détestez en vous
on est tombé j'ai l'impression d'avoir
une bouteille à la place du génial temps
j'ai l'impression d'avoir été vachement
bien ton et séverine qui l'aiment pas
sonné j'ai l'impression d'avoir un sac à
linge et de squales et des yeux d'algues
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma flotte au gré des mains
j'aurais loire ce que vous préférez dans
le théâtre
les trois coups la troupe ouais le
partage entre les comédiens et les
émotions qu'on se donne et qu'on reçoit
ce que vous n'aimez pas du tout dans le
théâtre les tensions ce que j'ai
l'impression que malgré tout chacun ses
petites habitudes et très vivant et bas
chacun ne veux pas en changer et donc le
tout c'était parfois de savoir prendre
sur soi ou de savoir dire les choses
clairement le plus grand moment de votre
vie
le sort de la générale
le pire moment de votre vie
le jour où mes deux grands parents ont
disparu et le doyen en l'occurrence
pendant que ce qui vous plaît le plus
dans la vie
l'ambition le fait de savoir de vouloir
mettre tout ce qu'on a en soi pour pour
arriver à quelque chose qu'on s'est
fixés ce qui nous fait vraiment chier
dans la vie
l'hypocrisie et les têtes de cons votre
plus gros coup de fric plus gros coup de
fric
honnêtement alors là je crois que j'en
ai pas fait parce que toutes les fois où
on m'a proposé justement surtout après
le loft parce qu'avant j'étais on m'a
proposé de faire pas mal de choses et
mon plus gros coup de fric c'est d'avoir
refusé de faire lofteurs open homme qui
avait rapporté chacun quand même un gros
paquet de fric
peu plus grosse perte mes grands parents
ouais l'autre plus belle histoire
d'amour
une jeune fille à l'époque où je
travaillais donc dans une discothèque
avec ce en provence avec qui je
travaillais j'étais tombé
follement amoureux d'elle et pareil
j'étais prêt à tout pour y arriver et
j'y suis arrivé
le plus minable histoire d'amour
celle là aussi ouais bah j'en ai eu deux
et les deux foires et donc il faut
choisir faut trancher ce que vous avez
des plus sexy
je sais pas mais main même si n'importe
quoi je sais pas d'un très beau cul
quand même hein c'est demain que vous
avez deux mois c'est que si
mon nez le pauvre mais qu'est ce qu'il
est avec son
aspect rémoise aucun
moment une obsession louis dit lui
très joli nez jean edouard
vous préférez dans le sexe
là le vrai que des gouttes dans le sexe
ça existe la chevrette qu'est ce qu'il
me doit
cesser ce comique ce que m
une des gouttes dans le sexe c'est
certain côté malsain qui peuvent être
poussés très bon mais où j'irai pas tu
aimes pas le sait que c'est mal ça tout
dépend ce qu'on appelle malsain pour les
gens une fellation sap est malsain et
pour d'autres coucher avec un cheval
c'est très malsain ouais ça dépend dans
quel cheval
joël edouard lipa et marie laforêt dont
jésus la cale à l'espace pierre cardin
et à partir du
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu